[Music]
wasun aerospace at Selita is actually a
production and manufacturing facility
for aircraft parts so this building
actually has office on one side and then
production facility on the other side
the objective was really to create this
conducive environment that is not just
for the manufacturing but a very very
nice space for people to work and plan
to stay in one of the biggest issue of
production and manufacturing facilities
at scale most of this facilities are so
low value picketers big box or a big
shell it's not so much for the human
what we're trying to do here is actually
to break it down to a smaller human
scale because in the end is really for
the people who are working there so that
you don't get one overall big chair but
three numbers or smaller buildings the
know the next thing you did was that we
peel off one part to create a sort of
internal courtyard inside now this
internal courtyard allows for light and
air comes through and the rain that
comes through there will be a lot more
natural ventilation to the building
there will be a lot more light that goes
through the building so the cost that
you've spent in the beginning to create
this courtyard would be offset by let's
say the reduction of the use of energy
in terms of light or and conditioning
what it also does is that it actually
creates a public space for people to
enjoy during lunchtime or during the tea
breaks well architecture is first and
foremost for people because all
buildings is not just purely functional
it should satisfy the spirit and the
soul so this is what we aspire to
you